after I picked up my daughter's ashes
from the funeral I went home and ate
some of them
[Music]
I found one of my old suicide notes in
my father's office she knew that I had
suicidal tendencies but never talked to
me about it or changed his abusive
behavior my biggest heartbreak was when
my father passed away from cardiac
arrest from shoveling the driveway after
I was taken in in an ambulance for my
suicide attempt I am dating four guys
simultaneously to cope with my
heartbreak that happened five years back
I recognized it as wrong but don't feel
guilty about it
that's crazy for guys some kids in my
class formed the whatsapp hate group of
my name a year back I recently found out
that my best friend is also a member in
it looking back at what my father made
me do to my younger cousins when I was 8
years old
I realized that I am a molester I would
imagine that would have really deep and
long-lasting negative effects on that
person and their cousins even they were
8 and they were being forced into doing
something so don't feel guilty because I
mean your 8 year old you really couldn't
consent to anything so I got raped at a
party my sophomore year of college I had
never been in a relationship and was
planning on saving myself for marriage
no one deserves to be like robbed of so
much especially someone who has never
been in a relationship to experience
like a violent kind of shattering of
your own personal boundaries is probably
like one of the most heartbreaking
things that can happen the one thing
that they can't take away from you is
your your own willingness of like giving
yourself to another person and open your
heart because I think that's what really
matters
my boyfriend manipulated and forced me
into having an abortion of our baby that
I really wanted to keep he called me
crazy and broke up with me a few months
later saying you're not getting over it
fast enough I'm paranoid that I can
never have a child again being in a
relationship with someone who's
manipulative is a very real thing and
give it a shot with someone else that
you really love don't discount the whole
idea my stepmom is very rude to me and
continuously breaks my heart I have ADHD
and each time I mess up she reminds me
how my friends that I don't hang out
often it hurts because I used to look up
to her I hope I can leave the house when
I become a teenager
well I think this makes me sad because
this is obviously someone who's pretty
young who wrote this
they're not even a teenager yet and to
have someone who's in your home was
supposed to love you and care for you be
the one that's actually antagonizing you
I think it's really it really sucks
their stepmom is human too what they say
is not necessarily true and they
shouldn't carry this with them yeah my
best friend and I would spend almost
every single day together people would
say our friendship was straight out of a
movie
I struggled a lot with depression
anxiety so one day I decided to tell him
all about my worries because of this he
started to become distant once when I
was ranting a lot he looked me in the
eyes and said I wish you would kill
yourself ready I still love him and hate
myself for that
[Music]
yeah that's scary like you it's like one
day there's someone your friends or
someone like you trust the most and then
another day they just kind of like
become like a whole different person I
think it takes a while to rebuild that
trust again with other people it's it's
hard the last few women I've slept with
have turned out to be a racist one of
them started calling a stranger black
slurs another night a different woman
shouted racist stereotypes at a stranger
as a black Latin woman it hurts
endlessly to know that people I shared
my body with could be so hateful towards
people that look like me well I imagine
it must be really startling and like a
punch in the face of sorts racism is one
of the most vile or hateful ways to
interact with someone
[Music]
our relationships or our past aren't
representative of who we are like just
because you have been with people who
have turned out to be evil or bad
doesn't that mean that you are
necessarily evil or bad or even if you
were racist in the past or if you were
had done bad things that doesn't define
who you are now
but it's really important to know and
recognize who it is that you are and how
is it how it is that you want to live
your life the other day I took a few
selfie pictures of myself and realized
how ugly I am it breaks my heart to
acknowledge how much I hate my face
that's really rough that's that's the
worst feeling there's a lot of pain in
feeling inadequate in your appearance
and just comparing yourself constantly
to other people who you perceive as more
attractive in society there's unspoken
standards of beauty which really impact
how confident you are when you're
interacting with people and that's very
unfortunate
once I wore my basic outfit white
t-shirt and jeans to my mom's birthday
party one of her friends who I've never
met before said to me that I am too fat
and need to lose weight the worst part
was that my mom heard it but said
nothing I left the party immediately
because I could not hold back my tears
like you already have
this part of yourself that it's like
very vulnerable and a complete stranger
like points it out very rudely and then
your mother also doesn't come to your
defense
come to support you I didn't always
think that the clothes I wanted to wear
suited me and there was like this moment
and I just think remember in middle
schools like in math class I just like I
like looked down I was like oh wow like
I don't feel great and like I couldn't
focus on anything else like I was in
class I was supposed to be learning but
that was all I could think of I don't
know I really wonder what what they did
after when they left the party I hope
they're okay
I just like take a walk maybe cry crying
feels better
you need that sometimes so
[Music]